hi everyone in today's video we're gonna
look at single Club full circles Gavin
already done so watch my video on single
Club pendulum swings after come back and
watch this video I'll put a link in the
description below okay so continuing on
from the pendulum swing let the momentum
carry on a bit higher so you end up in a
10 and 2 o'clock position as you
generate more momentum the coupe that
will go higher and eventually go all the
way around personally I find this
movement works better with the palm
facing up as the club's raising and some
palm facing down as the club's going
down so the first circle is going
inwards this time I'm going to reverse
the direction going outwards so from a
full circle you can do a basic hand
transfer and drop into a pendulum swing
and then just repeat the process on the
other side remember to keep your
shoulder down and now I'm extended as
you take it overhead so with that
movement I was going inwards this time
I'm going to reverse direction and go
outwards
okay so let's take a look at common
mistake this is where people try to lift
the club rather than using that mentor
this will result in the elbow collapsing
and the shoulder coming up you want to
be conscious of this and avoid at all
times so if you have all the correct
alignment when you poss should be nice
and upright and use the rotation of your
body to generate movement of the club
you can see here my clubs rotating on a
flat vertical play a bit exercise is to
imagine a wall in front of you I'll bet
they'll do it up against the wall and
this should ensure that you get correct
alignment of the club okay please leave
any feedback or questions in the
comments below and thanks again for
watching